لكنني أريد أن أبدأ من النقطة
التي لا تريد التحدث
عنها بالطبع كيف غادرت اليابان وجئت
إلى لبنان ، فأنا أعلم أنك
لن تقدم الكثير من التفاصيل ولكن هل يمكنك
الجوهر "إذا  الشائعات والاقتراحات
صحيحة إلى حد كبير حول الطريقة التي
حدث بها ،
فأنت تعلم أن الشائعات التي تعرفها ،
والاقتراحات هي أنها صحيحة في الأساس ،
وهناك العديد من الشائعات وهي
لا تتماشى مع بعضها البعض ،
وسأخبرك بشيء على سبيل المثال في
في البداية قالوا إن هناك
فرقة أتت إلى منزلي في طوكيو
لعيد الميلاد وأنت تعلم أنني حللت بطريقة ما
كانت نوعًا ما منها ، ثم
دخلت الصندوق وأخذوني من
المنزل وما إلى ذلك القصة كلها خاطئة لماذا
نظرًا لأن المدعي العام ذهب الآن إلى
شقتي ، فهناك مراقبة
لجميع الأشخاص الموجودين في المنزل
وقالوا لا ، لذا سأوضح الإشاعة
والاقتراح الذي أتحدث عنه يتضمن
رحلة بالقطار إلى أوساكا وصندوق فندق و
رحلة و je الخاص  إن ts
via Turkey دقيق للغاية
ولن أعلق على هذا ،
وسأخبرك لماذا ريتشارد لأنه من الواضح أنني
كنت محظوظًا لوجود أشخاص
دعموني في هذا لأنك تعلم عندما تكون
في موقف تكون فيه في مشكلة
مع العدالة ، ليس لديك الكثير من
المرشحين لمساعدتك ، لقد كنت محظوظًا
وأحتاج إلى حماية هؤلاء الأشخاص قدر الإمكان بشكل
صحيح ، حيث
يواجه بعضهم إجراءات جنائية محتملة
في تركيا ، ما هو شعورك حيال
شعوري بالسوء حيال ذلك  ولكن ليس هناك
الكثير الذي يمكنك القيام به بشكل جيد حقًا ، فأنت تعلم أننا
عرفنا منذ البداية ما هي
المخاطر التي تعرفها التي تنطوي عليها
عملية مثل هذه ، علمنا جميعًا أنني كنت
أعرف جيدًا مدى مخاطري ، كنت أعرف ما
هي مخاطر جميع الأشخاص الذين
دعمنا العملية ، لذلك عرفنا جميعًا
ذلك ومن الواضح أننا نعرف مقدار ما
يمكننا القيام به للمساعدة ولكن ليس أكثر حسنًا ماذا
عن السيد.  كيلي الذي لا يزال في
السجن دائمًا بكفالة ، استميحك بالعفو في
اليابان ، هذا هو نوع من
الشعور بأنك خرجت وتركت وراءك
لحمل الكاميرا جيدًا أولاً ، لم أتمكن
كما تعلم في اليابان من الاتصال بجريج ،
لقد مُنعت تمامًا
شرط الكفالة وحالة الكفالة الخاصة به
تمنع تمامًا أي اتصال
بيننا ، لذا كان الاتصال الوحيد الممكن
هو من خلال محامينا ، لذلك حتى لو
أردت مساعدة جريج ، لم أستطع
لأنه لم يكن هناك اتصال على الإطلاق ،
هل يمكنك فهم الشعور
بأنك  لقد تركته ليواجه الموسيقى
بمفرده ، لست متأكدًا من ذلك لأنني
لم أترك اليابان للاختباء في مكان ما
غادرت فيه اليابان لأنني أبحث عن
العدالة وأريد تبرئة اسمي
مما يعني أنني سأبحث  بالنسبة
لبلد يمكن أن أحاكم فيه هذه القضية
ولكن مع احترام المحاكمة
لحقوق الدفاع ، لذلك عليك توضيح
ذلك ، فأنت على استعداد للمحاكمة على
هذه الادعاءات ، نعم أفعل وقد
أجريت مناقشات مع السلطة القضائية  حتى
الآن إلى أين قد
لا يكون ذلك لأنه يمكنك أن تتخيل أنه إذا كنت
في اليابان ، فسوف أبدأ في مناقشة هذا النوع من
الموضوعات ، وهذا من شأنه أن يجذب الانتباه ،
ولكن هل تقبل أن تكون أي
محاكمة بموجب
القانون الياباني في  إن الإحساس بأن هذا هو القانون
الذي انتهكته ربما يكون نظام العدالة
يسلمه سيكون مختلفًا كما
أفكر في وجود سابقة جيدة
قد تكون على دراية بها بالطبع
مفجر لوكربي
الذي حوكم في لاهاي
والقانون الاسكتلندي  ليس نوع الشيء
الذي تفكر فيه لا ، فأنا أفكر
فيك أعرفه اعتمادًا على البلد الذي
سيحدث فيه هذا ، كل بلد
سيقبل نوعًا مختلفًا من المحاكمة ،
الشيء الوحيد الذي أبحث عنه هو تجربة
حيث القواعد أو
سيتم احترام حقوق الدفاع التي
اعتقدت في اليابان أنها لم تكن كذلك ، هناك
شيء واحد يبدو واضحًا هو أن
الآخرين في العالم يعتبرونك هاربًا
، وهذا لن يتغير ،
هل يجب عليك شرح ذلك جيدًا؟  أنت تعرف أن
الناس لا يحبون الهاربين عندما
يفرون من العدالة ، يكون
رأيًا مختلفًا عندما
يهرب الهارب من الظلم ، كما تعلم ، لا
أعتقد أن الناس ينظرون إلى الأشخاص الذين يفرون
من كوريا الشمالية أو من فيتنام أو من
روسيا في ظل الشيوعية  النظام نظرًا لأن
الناس يفرون من العدالة جيدًا
بصراحة يمكنني أن أخبرك أن هذا يعني
في النظام الذي
مررت به ، وأعتقد أنه لم يكن هناك
أي فرصة عمليًا للحصول على
محاكمة عادلة مع عدم وجود أي فرصة للحصول على
محاكمة عادلة لا أعتقد أن هذه عدالة
لم أكن أهرب من العدالة
كنت أبحث عن العدالة ، فما النقطة
التي قررت أن تحصل عليها قبل بضعة
أسابيع قبل بضعة أسابيع وما
قادني إلى ذلك أولاً هو ذلك  كل
ما قلته في المحاكمة التمهيدية كان يؤدي
إلى حقيقة أن المحاكمة لن تكون
ثانية عادلة كنت آمل أن ذلك
سيحدد تاريخ المحاكمة لم يتم
تحديدها حتى الآن لا أعرف أن جريج كيلي
لا يعرف  عندما تبدأ محاكمته 13
mon  بعد 13 شهرًا من
اعتقالنا وثالثًا الحظر المفروض على زوجتي
والذي كان حقًا شيئًا
لم أستطع فهمه لمدة تسعة أشهر يمكنني
رؤيتها يمكنني التحدث معها وأخبروني
أن هذا قد يستمر لمدة عام آخر
ونصف ثم قررت بعد ذلك
أنه كان كثيرًا جدًا ، هل
تقبل أنك انتهكت القانون الياباني
في تركك بهذه الطريقة ، فأنا أقبل حقيقة
أنهم انتهكوا القانون الياباني من خلال
العيش بهذه الطريقة ، نعم ، ربما تكون اليابان
قد انتهكت بالفعل  سمعوا اليوم أنهم
قالوا إن المدعي العام قال نتيجة
لمؤتمرك الصحفي هنا
أنك فشلت في تبرير تصرفك ، فقد تم
اعتبارك خطرًا على الهروب وهو ما حدث بالفعل
لأنك هربت وانتقاده الأحادي
الجانب لنظام العدالة الياباني
هو تمامًا  غير مقبول ، إنه مضحك ،
إنه أمر مضحك ، لقد كنت تحت
سيطرتهم طوال هذا الوقت ،
لقد وضعوا عليّ الكفالة ، شرط
أن تكون صارمًا للغاية ، لم يكن لدي
هاتف لا يمكنني الاتصال به على الإنترنت
، لم أستطع رؤية زوجتي.  ث  كما تم رصده
طوال الوقت ، كان لدي متابعون طوال
الوقت ، وبطريقة معينة عندما يكون
لديهم شك في شخص ما ، فإن ما
يرغبون فيه هو إبقائه في السجن حتى
يتم الحكم عليه ما ينتهي بهذا الشعور بأنه
لا يمكنك الاختيار  واختيار
القوانين التي تعجبك ، لا ، أنا متأكد من أن شركاتك
يمكنها اختيار الولايات القضائية التي تعجبك
، أنا متأكد من أنني لا أفعل ذلك ، ولكن إذا
لم أختار ، الشيء الوحيد الذي لا
أريده  كن نظامًا لا يوجد فيه
عدالة ، حوّلهم إلى الادعاءات
التي قدمتها لدفاع كامل للغاية
عن تلك المزاعم اليوم ،
ما الذي فعلته لدرجة أنه أغضب
الناس في اليابان لدرجة أن
المدعي العام والشركة قد تواطأوا على وجه اليقين.
هل تقوم بعمل جيد لم يعجبهم
حقيقة أنني كنت على استعداد للعمل من
جانب الإدارة بسبب
تراجع أداء الشركة وهذا
سبب آخر وهذا هو السبب الثاني
هو أنهم لم يعجبهم حقيقة أنني  كان على
وشك إنشاء شركة قابضة من
شأنها أن تنشئ شركة واحدة  مشاركة
لوحة واحدة ولكن مع الحفاظ على استقلالية
نيسان واستقلالية رينو
سليمة لا تحب النظام
وقلت لماذا يتعين علينا تقديم هذا النوع من
الامتياز الذي يتخلص من الرجل
والذي سيبقي مؤسستنا على ما هي
عليه  هو وبصراحة لقد
نجحوا في فعل ذلك عندما سمعت
عن مزاعم المنازل والطائرات
هل تعتقد أنك تستخدم العبارة التي
تدفع القارب بعيدًا قليلاً ، لقد
استفدت من النظام ليس
جيدًا على الإطلاق ، كان الجميع سعيدًا لأنني كنت  الرئيس
التنفيذي لثلاث شركات ولكن كونك رئيسًا تنفيذيًا
لثلاث شركات يعني استخدامًا مكثفًا
للطائرة ، فهذا يعني أن حياتك الخاصة
تنخفض إلى الحد الأدنى ومن
وقت لآخر عندما تكون قادرًا على الحصول على
لحظة محدودة للغاية وكل ذلك
لذلك كان الجميع سعداء عندما كنت
أدير الشركات الثلاث ثم
فجأة جاءت كل الشكوك
بالمناسبة كل شيء عن الطائرة
كل شيء عن المنازل ليس
في التهمة
التي تعني التهم في J  apan
ليس لها علاقة بأن الرسوم في
اليابان تتعلق بعدم الإبلاغ عن
التعويضات التي لم يتم إصلاحها ،
ولم يتم تحديدها ولم يتم دفعها
، فلن تحصل على هذه الأموال في
المستقبل ، لست متأكدًا ، لست متأكدًا من أنها كانت
النية
بشكل جيد  نيتي ولكن ليس
لأن لديك نية أن يكون لديك
شيء ما سيحدث كم
كان سيئًا في السجين بسبب سيء جدًا ،
أعني أن اليابان هي دولة من دول مجموعة السبع ، إنها
تريد كلمة أفضل ديمقراطية على النمط الغربي ،
الشركات التي أستخدمها  يعني أننا قد نحاربها في
جميع أنحاء العالم ، فأنت تخبرني أن هذا
ليس صحيحًا ، فكل الرحلات
هناك يوجد نقص كبير عندما
يتعلق الأمر بالنظام القانوني ،
حسنًا ، أعتقد أن هناك تباينًا كبيرًا
بين حداثة اليابان عندما
يتعلق الأمر  للصناعة عندما يتعلق الأمر بالتجارة
عندما يتعلق الأمر بالتكنولوجيا وعندما
يتعلق الأمر بالنظام القانوني في رأيي ،
فإن النظام القانوني قديم ، فأنت تعلم
أنهم ما زالوا يواجهون عقوبة
الإعدام بسبب أنهم فخورون جدًا بها.
أخبرني خلال المناقشة أن الأشخاص
الفخورين جدًا بأن لديهم عقوبة الإعدام
لديهم نظام يمكن من خلاله
استجوابك من قبل المدعي العام دون
حضور محام استجوبته
لفترات طويلة ، أعني أنني
أمضيت في السجن 130 يومًا من 130 يومًا.
أيام تم استجوابي عمليًا
نصف الوقت واستغرق الأمر ثماني ساعات
من الاستجواب في وقت متأخر جدًا من الليل ،
وهذا كل شيء بدون محام ولا محام ،
عندما شعرت يومًا
أنك ستعترف بأن هذا
ما يريدونني ، لا أنا  سمعتك تقول نعم
اعترف واعترف فقط وستشعر
بالارتياح واعترف فقط
ولن نضايق زوجتك فقط
نعترف بأننا لن نضايق
أطفالك ، كان من الواضح أنه موجود في الشريط
ولكن هل فكرت في الأمر  أفعل ذلك
أبدًا لأنني لم أكن أثق بهم ،
ولم أكن أثق بهم ، ولم أكن أثق بهم في
أنهم سيتوقفون عن فعل ذلك ، ولم أكن
أثق بهم في أنك ستحصل على أي عملية
إنقاذ ، لم أكن أثق بهم ، وأعتقد أنهم
لم تكن هنا
establi  لكن الحقيقة أنهم كانوا هنا
لتأسيس حجة قوية لصالحهم ،
فأنت لا تحصل على 99.4٪ من معدل الإدانة
لريتشارد من خلال كونك رجلًا لطيفًا
واتباع جميع القواعد ، فإنك تحصل على 99.4٪ من
معدل الإدانة دون أي صفقة مع عدم وجود
صفقة في  معدل الإدانة في الولايات المتحدة
مرتفع للغاية ولكن في الولايات
المتحدة يمكن أن تعقد صفقة كما تعلم أن الناس
يقولون حسنًا ، أنت مذنب وسأقدم
لك تخفيضًا لهذا التخفيض
ليس في اليابان ، هل كنت ستبرم
صفقة ما يعتمد على ما  هل ما
أعنيه جيدًا ما أقوله هو أن التطبيق كان
على الأقل ستستمع إليه - ماذا
لو لم تكن هناك صفقة هناك ،
فلا يوجد أي اتفاق على الإطلاق ، لذلك
عندما تقول إن لديك 99.4٪ من
معدل الإدانة  مع عدم وجود صفقة مع عدم وجود صفقة ، فهذا
يعني أنهم ربحوا تسعة وتسعين فاصل أربعة في
المائة من الوقت مما يجعل
المدعي العام رائعًا
تمامًا والدفاع ليس أذكياء على الإطلاق وليس
الأشخاص ليسوا أذكياء جدًا ، لذا فإن فكرة
أنه لا يوجد دخان بدون نار
لفكرة ذلك  كيف تأتي على السيارات م  لقد
كنت مستيقظًا تمامًا مثلما أعلم أن هذا يعني أنه
كان يعيش على مستوى عالٍ من
أموال الشركة ، نعم حسنًا ، أنت تعلم بصراحة أن
هذا يعني أن هذا قديم قدم الكلمة
الموجودة ، كما تعلم إذا كنت تريد أن
تكذب على شخص ما وكانوا كذلك  في
سمعة القصة ، أطلقت الكثير من
الاتهامات وتقول إن شيئًا ما سيظل
ثابتًا لديك مجالان أخريان للحديث
عنك ، يمكنك الوصول إلى لبنان
والبلد في حالة اضطراب ، نعم إنها تبحث عن
حكومة تبحث عن قيادة
حزبية مباشرة ، هل
تريد  أنت تقبل دورًا ما في
الحكومة اللبنانية ، لا ، قلت إنني أعلم أنني
ضربت الآن قلت من قبل وقلت
في المستقبل إنني لست مهتمًا
بالمهنة السياسية ، فأنا مستعد لوضع
كفاءتي ومعرفي في المساعدة
ينجح السياسيون ولكني لست
مهتمًا بالعمل السياسي ، لذا دعني
أخبرك إذا تمت دعوتك لتكون
رئيسًا ، فستقول لا إذا
طلب منك رئيسك أن تصبح تشكيل حكومة عبر
الحزب ، فستقول ذلك بالضبط
سيشعر  لي  أنت في سجن لطيف للغاية
حيث لا يمكنك الذهاب إلى أي مكان باستثناء
ربما إلى فرنسا أو البرازيل
وستجد صعوبة في الوصول إلى كليهما
وستتعرض لمخاطر شخصية هائلة ، لذا
هل ستقبل ذلك  تعتمد المخاطرة التي تهتم
بها لفرنسا جيدًا على ما يعتمد
على ما يعتمد على المنظور
الذي تعرفه ، من الواضح أنك تخبرني أن
وضعي اليوم ليس مثاليًا ، إنه ليس
مثاليًا أتفق معك ولكن يجب
مقارنته بوضعي قبل
كان الوضع من قبل
في سجن عمليًا وسجنًا مختلفًا
في اليابان خارجًا بدون أصدقائي
بدون عائلتي دون مجتمعي
حيث لا تتحدث اللغة وما إلى
ذلك ، هذا هو هذا الفيديو ، لذا فأنا الآن في
لبنان حيث يوجد بلد  يعجبني
حيث لدي أصدقاء لدي عائلة ، لذا
نعم ، قد أكون مقيدًا بالحظر
لفترة من الوقت ولكني
أنوي إلغاء القول لفترة من الوقت
بطريقة محيرة كما لو كانت
هناك خطة مؤكدة  أعلم أنه يمكنني
التحدي  النشرة الحمراء للانتربول يمكنني
أن أتحدىها ولدي الحق في
تحديها وسأقوم
بتحديها لأنني لا أعتقد أنني أعتقد أن هذه
القضية سياسية سأنتهي منها
لأن الوقت ينفد
بالحديث عن التحالف ، التحالف
الذي جمعته معًا ، يبدو أنه ينهار تقريبًا ،
مما يشير إلى أنه
يمكن أن يظل سويًا فقط مع
رحيل الديكتاتور كارلا ، ولا أعتقد
ذلك ، لذا فأنا أولاً لا أعتقد أن ديكتاتورًا كان
بإمكانه إنشاء التحالف الأول  لا
أعتقد ذلك ، أعتقد أن الدكتاتور
لن يكون قادرًا على إنشاء مساحة حيث
يمكن للناس أن يجتمعوا على الرغم من
أنهم يأتون من بلدان
مختلفة في ثقافة مختلفة ، فهذا يتطلب الكثير
من المهارات من حيث
التفاوض بين الأشخاص الذين يأتون إليها  الجدول
لأنه كان من مصلحتهم الخاصة ، لذلك
ولم يكن الدكتاتور دي كلير
قادراً على القيام بذلك الآن ، دعني أذهب إلى
الشيء الثاني ، نعم ، لا يسير التحالف على ما
يرام ، ليس لأنني لا غنى
عني على ما أعتقد ولكن أعتقد  الطريقة التي
يتم استخدامها اليوم في السطور
ليست فعالة على الإطلاق وهذا
ما أزعجني أدركت أنك تعلم
أن التحالف هو عمل حياتك
لأنه لا يوجد حتى وميض من
الشماتة بالطريقة
التي حصلوا بها على أنفسهم  في حالة من الفوضى
وهذا يبدو أن الأرباح تنخفض بشكل كبير وأنا
أعلم أنه فشل في التقاط Fiat
Chrysler Mitsubishi لم يستدير ،
أليس كذلك ، أليس هذا مجرد لحظة
تقول فيها تخلصت مني ، انظر إلى ما
انتهى بك الأمر  بدون أدنى شك ، أنت
تعرف أن العديد من الأشخاص قالوا إننا نريد
قلب الصفحة التي تم حذفها جيدًا ، لقد قلبوا الصفحة المفقودة
باستثناء أن الصفحة التي تم
حذفها كانت عبارة عن ديناميات استراتيجية لنمو الأرباح
والابتكار التكنولوجي والتحالف الذي يعمل
اليوم عندما ننظر إلى  الوضع نعم ،
لقد قلبوا الصفحة ، لم يعد هناك ربح ، ولم يعد هناك المزيد من
الربح ، ولم يعد هناك
المزيد من الابتكار التقني ، ولم يعد هناك
المزيد من المبادرات الإستراتيجية ، أو
كانت المبادرة الإستراتيجية الوحيدة هي شركة كرايسلر الأولى
التي كانت  ost التي تم تحليلها لا تعمل كما
كانت اللحظة بالنسبة لك عندما
أدركت أنك هربت من أشخاص مختلفين ،
فسوف يصدر حكمًا أخلاقيًا
وقانونيًا على ما فعلته ، وهو
شيء سيتعين عليك تحمل
ضميرك نعم
حتى الموت ولكن من أجلك في
تلك اللحظة عندما  - أريد أن أذهب إلى
قسمين منه في اللحظة
التي بدأت فيها تنفيذ الخطة خلال
ثلاثة ، وفي النهاية أخبرني نعم
سأخبرك بالضبط ما هو الوضع
الذي لم أرَ فيه شخصًا يفر من
السجن في فيتنام  من كان لديه أي
شعور سيء حيال القيام بذلك ، لماذا
لأنه كان رهينة ولم يكن يفر
من حكم القانون في فيتنام ، قال
إنني رهينة هم هنا لكي يعاقبوا
، ليس لدي محاكمة عادلة وأنا أهرب
لذلك أنا في نفس الموقف ، فأنا لا
أشعر بالسوء لأنني بطريقة ما وضعت نفسي
خارج سيطرة الأشخاص الذين يريدون
مني أن زجني في السجن بشكل مستقل
عن الحقيقة ولكن هل كنت متوترًا ، نعم ،
كنت متوترة هل كنت تخشى ذلك
سوف أخطأ
أنا  كنت قلقة لكنني لم أكن خائفًا
لسبب بسيط للغاية هو أنه بصراحة لم
يكن لدي ما أخسره ، مما يعني أن
الوضع في اليابان كان سيئًا للغاية ،
كان وجهة نظري قاتمة للغاية
وحقيقة أنني فقدت أي وجه من الحصول على محاكمة عادلة
أن هذا  شجعتني على أن
أقرر مغادرة اليابان وفي اللحظة التي أعني فيها
الدعابة ،
نعم ، في اللحظة التي تكون فيها الطائرة
مساحة دولية وأنت
تعلم تمامًا أنها ستهبط في لبنان ، كيف كانت
تلك اللحظة ولكن كما تعلم
لن تهبط في لبنان
كانت ستهبط في مكان آخر
لكنني شعرت بالراحة بعد ذلك شعرت بالارتياح نعم
شعرت بالارتياح - ثلاثة وأنت تعلم
أن أول ما قلته هو
أنني سأتمكن أخيرًا من رؤية زوجتي
ولهذا السبب أولاً وقبل كل شيء  سأعمل على
هذا فقط وآمل أن تعطيني
إجابة عما كان عليه الحال في علبة التعبئة ،
انظر إلى الحرية بغض النظر عن
الطريقة التي تحدث بها دائمًا
[موسيقى]